our data scientists quitting their jobs
in significant levels in this video I'm
gonna break down the evidence that this
is actually happening the reasons it's
probably happening and then my two cents
on where we go from here
I'm Richard and this is Richard on data
[Music]
so you would be forgiven for just
assuming that its clickbait but there
are articles one after another on medium
and on other publication websites
talking about data scientists quitting
their jobs now this might seem a little
weird and it certainly flies directly in
the face of all the people claiming that
data science is the sexiest job of the
21st century and playing up how much
money that you can make in the role
granted this sort of thing has been part
of the workplace culture at least in the
United States for quite some time but
there is a lot of chatter about this
happening in data science to a
particularly great extent and I think
the first natural question is how big is
this migration of data scientists out of
their jobs and then before we talk about
reasons why it's happening what's the
evidence that it's happening in the
first place before I do that I do ask
that you subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and also hit the
notification bell so YouTube notifies
you whenever I upload a video hit the
like button too if you can spare 1.5
seconds of your day because that really
does help my content reach a larger
audience also I am on patreon and I'll
have a link to that in the description
if you would be willing to support me
that way I do greatly appreciate it
there certainly are a few data points
which point to that data scientists are
actually leaving their jobs so in
particular the Financial Times has done
a piece on this and there's a couple of
surveys that they point to
so in particular Cagle did a survey of
people and their finding was that data
scientists we're spending one to two
hours of their day each week looking for
jobs so that's pretty fascinating but
then Stack Overflow surveyed 64,000
developers and they found that the two
kinds who are most likely to be looking
for a job were machine learning
specialists and they
to scientists these are certainly
meaningful things but I will say it is
still a little challenging to exactly
grasp how big or how widespread of a
problem this actually is and that's in
part because I really don't know how
representative kegels user base or stack
overflows developer community is of the
broader data science community as a
whole and that would be very interesting
to know because it's always really
fascinating to see how these things
change across geographical and income
lines but still there's enough people
talking about this issue to where
there's at least probably a little bit
of they're there and it's worth at least
having a conversation about so based on
my own opinions and anecdotes and my
research mostly from reading a lot of
the articles that people have written on
this topic I'm gonna give to you five
big reasons that are standing out for
why I think this is happening so the
first reason is actually a pretty
important piece of context to keep in
mind now I'm by no means an expert on
all the various economies across the
world but it is important to notice that
in the last decade most economies all
around the world have experienced a
pretty reasonable period of economic
growth granted before the global
pandemic occurred the United States
anyway was what's known as an employee's
market that is the unemployment rate was
very low and it was very common to see
people leave their jobs and just go
somewhere else that they just generally
liked more or that was willing to pay
them more money that's especially true
in jobs that pay more and data science
does fall under that category data
scientists have a lot of skills and with
a lot of skills comes mobility it is
really easy to move around and find
something that suits you better keep in
mind data science has only really been
around since 2011 and during that entire
time period at least until March of 2020
the United States anyway has been
experiencing economic growth and falling
unemployment economically we are moving
into a new era now
we cope with the global pandemic as well
as the resulting economic fallout
so just because data scientists have
been quitting their jobs in the last few
years even if that's true that does not
necessarily mean that they're still
going to keep that trend going in the
future they might but we simply don't
know that yet so just keep that in mind
the overall macroeconomic picture does
count a lot into this now that reason is
not something that a lot of the articles
out there seem to be talking about a lot
but I do think it is one of the single
biggest factors that's going on here as
far as the articles are concerned the
single biggest reason that they
rightfully point to for data scientists
leaving their jobs is expectations not
matching reality and I've talked about
this again and again in my videos but
academia and some people in the industry
really do push an incredibly misleading
picture of what data science actually is
they'll tell you that you spend all day
building really complex sexy
amazing-looking neural network models
and that is what the day to day of a
typical job looks like your courses or
books that you're working from give you
super clean tidy looking data sets which
require little to no upfront work on
your end whatsoever they're ready to go
they're ready for you to do your magic
and make an awesome model nothing can be
further from the truth at least as a
general rule I really hope this problem
goes away at least a little bit in the
coming years as educators become a
little bit pressured to paint more
accurate pictures of what data science
actually is and additionally I do hope
more educational resources become
available which really demonstrate what
real world data looks like real world
data is messy and confusing and it does
a bit of a disservice to people just
providing clean research style datasets
I think it's also inherent to data
scientists to want to work on projects
that are enormous ly impactful because
it's really easy to learn inferential or
predictive
rhythms and just be able to imagine how
these things can drive major awesome
change unfortunately though there are a
ton of moving parts that go into driving
major organizational change and it
happens all the time in the business
world that projects get started but they
ultimately don't end up going anywhere
it's just the reality that most data
scientists are absolutely going to
deliver economic value but that value is
going to be smaller and more incremental
and there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that that's just something that you
need to be aware of and calibrate
yourself to the next up is the fact that
data scientists typically do not enjoy
playing politics so here's what I'll say
about this one I talk a lot in my videos
about what an important role
communication plays in data science
because you can work on this awesome
visualization or app or model or
whatever it is but the overwhelming
majority of the time that stuff does no
good until you have explained it to
somebody and that person has bought into
it and that can be a real pain people
distrust models they don't understand
them these are very true things
additionally sometimes you have to get
along with people or impress somebody
and that means doing a little more work
than you want to or just doing work that
you frankly feel kind of overqualified
to do I know this has happened to me a
little bit in the past myself overall
this one is probably going to depend on
the age and size of your organization as
well as its data department and culture
and this is something that I think
current and aspiring data scientists Oh
to themselves to look at when you look
at a job description or you go for an
interview for a data science job try to
ascertain if that company actually has
the culture and the infrastructure
that's required to actually adequately
support data science frankly it's been
surveyed quite recently that as many as
72 percent of business executives don't
believe that they've created a
data-driven culture or a data-driven
organization and that's a topic in and
of itself but there's
tons of downstream problems that come
out of that that can mean that it's just
analysis paralysis when it comes to
doing relevant necessary new analysis or
building new infrastructure it could
mean that it's like pulling teeth to get
buy-in on things or my personal favorite
the next item on this list and that
being the go-to person for all things
data and the organization there's really
not that much to say about this one
except that if you get the sense that
the company wants this kind of person
that means you need to run fast and run
far away this should mainly be an issue
with smaller rather than larger
companies but these are the types of
organizations that will provide lists in
their job descriptions of 30 different
programming languages or technologies or
methods that you need to be familiar
with and you need to be an expert at
absolutely everything you work with
databases you do machine learning you
produce reports you're an expert at
everything that happens in the
production and deployment lifecycle
absolutely everything this just screams
of the company trying to be
strategically competitive by breaking
into data in the first place but they
have absolutely no idea how to do it so
they figure the first thing they're
gonna do is just find a body and throw
that person at it and it virtually
guarantees that you're not gonna have
any of the supports or infrastructure
that you need to be successful so again
if you see this kind of thing just run
away now the last reason is over lack of
upscaling opportunities so you've been
working at your job for some time and
you start to realize that over the last
six months to a year you've kind of been
working on the same types of projects
over and over and you really haven't
developed any new skills that you can
add to your resume and this is really an
easy one to sympathize with because
there are a lot of boring aspects of the
job you've got cleaning data you've got
playing politics I mean nobody said that
it was going to be fun from start to
finish but there's got to be something
in there that keeps things exciting the
data science field as a whole carries
with it a lot of pressure to learn new
skills and I
don't need to go through that list of
skills in this video because I make fun
of it all the time
but the need to upskill is completely
legitimate and it's not something that
I'm gonna belittle or make fun of here
because data science is an enormous ly
technical field and with it comes
enormous developments all the time so
it's incredibly important for people's
long-term career prospects to at least
keep some level of awareness or
experience with these developments so
when you combine getting bored with not
living up to the pressures which are
imposed by the field yeah it's really
easy to see why this could potentially
be a problem and hopefully this is
something that sorts itself out
organically as HR professionals and data
professionals work together to increase
employee retention and just to generally
create data departments that people want
to work in that stay in the cutting edge
of technology and just provide long term
meaningful work for people to do so
overall I'm gonna come back to the fact
that a lot of people at least in the
u.s. just simply don't have the same
culture and attitude towards their
employer that they did years and years
ago most of the time you just don't work
at a place for 30 years anymore you work
somewhere until you're no longer
learning anything new or the culture no
longer supports your professional
development or your lifestyle then you
find somewhere else or alternatively you
just find a job that just pays you more
money and you go with that and that's
doubly so with data scientists who have
a skill that's highly sought after in
the marketplace and that fact may have
more to do with data science flight than
anything which is systemic to the data
science field as a whole but in the end
employee turnover of any type can hurt
organizations and there are a few things
which I do hope happen number one
academia stopped pushing a false
narrative about what data science
actually practically is because it leads
to people having severely misleading
expectations number two prospective data
scientists develop a stronger BS radar
for companies that just simply do not
have the necessary culture and interest
structure to support them or that just
generally expect them to be the go-to
person for all things data and then
number three more companies learn from
each other about what it means to be a
data-driven organization as well as how
to successfully incorporate data science
into their products and services if we
see more of these things in the future I
have a feeling data scientists will be
pretty happy with their jobs as we move
into this decade so thanks for watching
this video if you enjoyed it and you'd
like to support my work please consider
sharing this video otherwise again
please hit the like button and leave me
a comment down below let me know
especially if you've quit your data
science job because I would love to hear
from you otherwise I'll see you all in
the not so distant future
until then richard on data